I have worked outside of the home
and I have come home at the end of the day not wanting to cook.
So just because I'm a stay at home wife and mom now
doesn't mean I've never had a job or I've never had that experience.
Not saying cooking from scratch is easy to do,
but I am saying it is doable to do
because people do have the time to do these things if they want to.
It's just the matter that it's easier to get take out and I.
It's fine if you do that.
I'm not saying you're a bad person if you get take out.
But the people who say that oh, you have money or you have time,
so therefore your privilege,
people don't have that privilege.
We live in a day and age where you have bread machines.
We live in a day and age where you have instant pots and Crock Pots
and an instant pot can make meat tender within like 45 minutes.
We're not rich,
we're lower income, like lower middle class,
lower come side of things.
Like I understand how expensive things can be.
About willpower and doing the things you don't wanna do
and not doing the easy thing that is to do.
And again, I don't care if you could take out,
we could take out sometimes because guess what?
I'm exhausted at the end of the day and I don't wanna cook.
So I fully sympathize. With it